It's been quite the journey, but WandaVision
has reached its final episode.
What began as a love letter to classic TV
slowly transformed into a tale of confusion,
betrayal, grief and more.
Here's how WandaVision wrapped up its small-screen
tenure, and what the finale means for the
MCU's future.
After holding Wanda's twin sons hostage and
forcing her to relive her past trauma, Agatha
continues her pursuit of Wanda's power.
As noted in last week’s episode, Wanda is
apparently the legendary Scarlet Witch -- a
being capable of unmatched creation and destruction
-- so naturally, Agatha is prepared to go
to great lengths to take Wanda's Chaos Magic
for herself.
The two battle in the series finale, using
their abilities against one another, but Wanda
is effectively powerless.
Every time she tries to fight back against
Agatha, the ancient witch absorbs the energy
for herself.
This leads Wanda to get crafty -- witchcrafty,
if you will -- sneaking up from behind and
using the mind-control trick she used back
in her first appearance in 2015's Avengers:
Age of Ultron.
Her illusion sends Agatha back to the day
she killed off her witch coven, though the
seasoned magic-user quickly turns the spell
around on her.
In response, Wanda breaks it and takes the
fight to Agatha directly, before seemingly
giving up and handing over her Chaos Magic
willingly.
Her body turns dark and withered and Agatha
gains the strength she desires, but Wanda
has one more trick up her sleeve.
Wanda reveals that she placed runes on the
interior walls of the Hex, and regains the
lifeforce it seemed Agatha had drained from
her.
Just as Agatha taught her, only the witch
who cast them can use their magic in a confined
space.
This gives her the chance to reabsorb her
power and take the form of the Scarlet Witch,
overpowering her enemy.
Defeated and desperate, Agatha pleads with
Wanda to no avail, forced to live out her
days in her chatty alter-ego, Agnes.
It's rare for villains to outlive their introduction
in the MCU, so it's pretty much a given that
Agatha will return somewhere down the line.
In fact, it seems almost like a guarantee.
"You're gonna need me."
"If I do, I know where to find you."
The only question left now is just how soon
we'll see her again -- in Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness?
Or somewhere further down the line?
A major surprise came at the tail end of WandaVision's
eighth episode, unveiling S.W.O.R.D.'s "White
Vision" for the first time.
The synthezoid specter got the chance to show
off what he can do this week, nearly crushing
Wanda's skull and going head-to-head with
the Hex-bound Vision of her creation.
The majority of the two Visions' confrontation
gives longtime Marvel fans the kind of laser
beam-shooting, hand-to-hand action they've
been waiting for, but not for long.
After clashing for a short while, the Visions
share an intellectual debate concerning the
nature of their existence.
Levitating inside Westview's library, Vision
presents White Vision with the Ship of Theseus
thought experiment.
The theory asks that if the ship's rotting
pieces are continually replaced over time,
does the ship eventually cease to exist, since
its original form will eventually be depleted?
“I request elaboration.”
They apply that question to themselves, noting
that Westview's Vision lacks a physical form
but contains the Vision's soul, and White
Vision retains the original's synthetic body
and memories, filed away as "data" in his
"memory storage,” but doesn't have the Vision's
personality.
Therefore, are either of them truly Vision?
“Neither is the true ship.
Both are the true ship.”
To put this debate to bed, the Wanda-created
Vision unlocks his double's memories, who
has realized that the knowledge of his true
self was being suppressed by Hayward, in order
to make him "a weapon to be more easily controlled."
With his data restored, the White Vision leaves
Westview and disappears for the rest of the
series finale.
But it's safe to assume that he'll make his
return in a future MCU project.
When -- and whether or not he'll attempt to
reconnect with Wanda -- are questions only
time can answer.
In the midst of their magic-slinging confrontation,
Agatha begins to play some serious mind games
with Wanda.
This includes her awakening a handful of Westview's
residents, leading them to surround Wanda
and beg for mercy.
They say they share in her pain and either
want to be freed or die because the suffering
that comes with living under her trance is
unbearable.
This causes Wanda to panic, so she opens the
Hex and allows the people to escape her clutches
-- that is, until she notices Vision, Billy,
and Tommy disintegrating, as their existences
are tied to the Hex.
Later on, with Agatha defeated and the Hex
completely wiped from Westview, the townspeople
still seem to hold plenty of ill-will toward
Wanda, shooting her the stink-eye on her way
out of the community.
Thankfully, Jimmy Woo and an FBI task force
show up to help the now-freed residents, but
that doesn't absolve Wanda of her wrongdoings.
She held an entire town against their will
and unwittingly caused them real harm for
quite a long time.
That's something that doesn't go away in the
blink of an eye, and Wanda's guilt will likely
last just as long as the psychological damage
she caused for every one of them.
Chances seem good that we'll be hearing about
Westview again in a future MCU project soon
-- just as the consequences of the battles
in Sokovia and Lagos reverberated after Avengers:
Age of Ultron and Captain America: Civil War.
After it briefly appeared in WandaVision's
seventh installment, "Breaking the Fourth
Wall," viewers finally got a good look at
Agatha's magical book, the Darkhold.
"That's the book of the damned."
The longtime witch first mentions it by name
in the series finale, telling Wanda that the
Darkhold contains an entire chapter devoted
solely to the Scarlet Witch -- a powerful
sorceress who defies the usual rules of witchcraft.
Agatha notes that it's Wanda's destiny to
destroy the world.
This moment must've piqued Wanda's interest,
as she's shown reading the so-called "Book
of the Damned" in the show's final post-credits
scene.
Unsurprisingly, the Darkhold is a storied
artifact from the pages of Marvel Comics,
dating back to 1972's Marvel Spotlight #4,
where it's described as a collection of spells
and techniques of dark magic.
Over the years, the Darkhold has had many
owners -- including the sorceress Morgan Le
Fay, who bound it from a collection of parchments
into the unholy book it would become, and
even the Sorcerer Supreme, Doctor Strange.
Considering both Wanda's devotion to understanding
the Darkhold's knowledge and Doctor Strange's
comic history as one of its previous owners,
it's a safe bet that the Darkhold is coming
with her when she shows up in Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness.
And given the fact that she hears her kids
crying for help as she reads through the book
in the scene's final moments, there's a pretty
good chance she'll seek out the good doctor's
help so she can rescue them from whatever
dimension they may now be trapped within.
As Marvel Comics fans may recall, Billy and
Tommy are revealed to be shards of a demon's
soul in 1989's ﻿Avengers West Coast﻿ #52.
Could the MCU's take on Wanda's powerful progeny
be trapped in Hell itself?
Of course, devoted fans know that this isn't
the first time we've seen the Darkhold in
the MCU.
Its first screen appearance was actually in
season four of Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
There, it was established that the shape-changing
book has long been a powerful artifact in
the MCU, and it wound up playing a large role
in the Phil Coulson-led team's dealings with
the newest version of Ghost Rider, among other
shenanigans.
It next appeared in the late, lamented hulu
original Runaways, and was wielded by the
evil sorceress Morgan le Fay.
Just how the book ended up in Agatha's possession
-- or even if Marvel Studios will recognize
its previous appearances in the now-defunct
Marvel Television productions -- remains to
be revealed.﻿﻿
After a week away from the WandaVision spotlight,
Monica Rambeau had a bit more to do in "The
Series Finale."
Not only did Monica take down Agatha's fake
take on Quicksilver, who's neither a recast
version of the MCU Pietro, nor the X-Men version
from a different universe -- Instead, he's
actually just some guy named Ralph Bohner.
"Bohner."
But Monica also got to test out her burgeoning
powers.
With the Hex down, Director Hayward and his
S.W.O.R.D.
cronies burst on the scene.
When Hayward fires his gun at Wanda's kids
Billy and Tommy, Monica steps in.
She uses her phasing abilities to alter her
physiology, thus stopping the bullets from
hitting the twins.
With the help of Darcy Lewis, Hayward is apprehended
and his plan is foiled, leaving Jimmy Woo
and Monica Rambeau to clean up Westview.
In the first of the WandaVision finale's two
post-credits scenes, a S.W.O.R.D.
agent ushers Monica into the local movie theater
to speak with her.
Revealing herself to be a Skrull, the agent
mentions that an old friend of Monica's mother,
Maria Rambeau, sent her and wants to arrange
a meeting.
When asked where, the Skrull then points upward,
indicating that their conversation will take
place in space.
Could this be a follow-up to the end-credits
scene from Spider-Man: Far From Home, where
Nick Fury is shown sitting comfortably aboard
a massive, Skrull-filled spacecraft?
Or is the Skrull referring to the return of
Talos?
Alternatively, is this a setup for Monica's
inclusion in Captain Marvel 2 via a reunion
with Carol Danvers?
Time will tell, but it's clear that Monica's
story is far from over.
In keeping with the series of unending tragedies
that is Wanda Maximoff's life, her perfect
fictional world finally comes crashing down
at the end of the WandaVision series finale.
With Agatha defeated, the people of Westview
freed, and S.W.O.R.D. as well as the FBI on
her case, Wanda is left no other choice but
to take down the Hex.
Streets and shops begin returning to their
natural state, and the time of day once again
matches the outside world.
The disintegrating Hex closes in on the family,
and Wanda knows it's inevitable that Billy,
Tommy, and Vision will disappear from existence.
Before that happens, the family returns home
after a long day of battle, begrudgingly prepared
to bid one another farewell.
First, Wanda and Vision tuck their twins into
bed, and she thanks them for choosing her
as their mother as the Hex's borders draw
nearer.
Wanda and Vision then enter the living room
to say their final goodbyes to each other.
Wanda reveals this Vision exists thanks to
the elements of the Mind Stone that live inside
of Wanda.
They embrace, with the synthezoid predicting
that, much like before, they'll meet again
someday in some form.
He then disappears, leaving Wanda alone once
again on the plot of land where they once
planned to build their home.
On paper, WandaVision is a tough sell: It's
about a powerful witch who crafts a fake reality
to avoid properly grieving the loss of her
true love, who was previously killed -- twice
-- several movies ago.
Couple that with Wanda and Vision's super-powered
children, the recast Pietro Maximoff, the
people Wanda took hostage, Agatha's whole
deal in general, S.W.O.R.D.'s status as mostly
good guys but also partially bad guys, and
the weird-factor only increases.
Even still, the cast and crew involved managed
to turn this risky premise into something
truly special.
WandaVision made fans laugh, cry, and everything
in between, and is sure to spark conversation
and debate for a good long time to come.
If this is the level of quality viewers can
expect from Marvel Studios' Disney+ offerings,
then the MCU's future is very bright, indeed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.